we need some way to road-test a more
rural friendly message your principles
in the bad times I guess their
principles it just hobbies nice John
Wayne and a tractor have a baby and all
you can say it's nice oh my god my first
question is this film is set in a small
town why do you think it was important
to tackle like someone like politics in
a small town for this film you know in
some respects it could have been set
anywhere it's really more about how the
system around elections no longer serves
the citizens that it purports to serve
so the setting had more to do with kind
of playing into the political divide
that we have in this country so that you
the story has some credibility as you
begin to watch it so you kind of forget
so that at the end when you reveal kind
of the real purpose of the movie is to
get kind of the idea that dad the
audience believe they're watching a
different movie than the one that
they're actually watching and so it had
to exist in a way that I think the
audience believes could happen could
play into the narratives that we've been
fed yeah absolutely I mean the casting
was great all over Chris Cooper was
phenomenal as a choice - yeah such a
rock I want to talk about Steve Carell
because you guys have obviously worked
together way back in the day and I want
to know how has he grown as a performer
working with him then and then working
with him now not at all to watch him
wither
I mean he was a talented man with a real
zest for life and to see him now just
this husk I mean if I hadn't sworn his
parents that I would take care of him I
don't know that I ever would know he's
you know when we were on The Daily Show
a Steve Carell segment was always he
almost made
you lazy as a writer because you knew he
was going to find things in between the
lines that were unbelievable what he's
really done since then is developed a
crack as an actor as someone who can
bring nuance to a character that's not
just comedic but emotive and he's just
such a versatile and talented performer
it's just a shame about the drug problem
I feel like there's a lot of that
whenever he would give like a speech or
a monologue he would kind of like play
with it anyway and he gave a lot of
really interesting moments that were fun
for me in the Edit because in the Edit
you know you're watching this thing ten
thousand times and when you have actors
of that caliber you're picking new
things up that they've done reacting to
each other or additive things that are
really help fill out scenes so that was
always fun you know it makes it a much
more fun process even in the Edit
obviously politics is very much on a lot
of people's minds right now I want to
know what you hope people will take away
from this film well hopefully they'll
think it's a funny enjoyable you know
power and whatever it is hour in 30
hours 30 minutes you know the main thing
you want to do is hope people have an
entertaining time with it and think it's
funny and resonates for them in some
kind of way as far as the what they take
away from it I think that would be the
main thing and it could cause us some
moment of inspiration that the system
hopeful that the system can be changed
you know to change a system you have to
be able to diagnose it as to what's
really the illness and what's going on
and hopefully this gives people a chance
to think about those things and and put
us on that path because you know I've
been very encouraged to see all the
grassroots activism and work being done
by people right now and it's exciting
this is really just another perfect
example of the DC Li trying to dictate
how we should live that's we your DC
elite oh I know actually I'm from here
I'm from dear Lacan
that's a lie that's a lot no that's what
are you doing one of my favorite moments
from from your character from faith is
when she's on like the video called
doing her television interview and she
just has a very like straight like stoic
face and a very stiff politician face
where did where did that come from where
did that inspiration come from you know
I've always been a fan of the genre of
sort of films about the media films
about politics whether it's broadcast
news or the newsroom the recent Apple
show it's such a great backdrop for
drama and theatrics
and there's a specific tone with with
the with the job that I think is
required and I was fascinated to try to
capture that and it's very
nerve-wracking to be honest because of
the politico speak is like another
language it really is and I don't know
what so I was desperately trying to
there is a almost a boredom or a
dullness sometimes when people win there
and they just don't draw breath that's
the other thing there's no grass saying
there's no effort so I try to capture
that while whilst you know knowing that
language well how do you get to know
that type of character was it just like
previous experience or was such a source
of information you know I was like you
know tell me what I think he's known so
many faiths in his life so many faiths
from Washington weather and eat me you
know he directed me to that great
documentary the war room and there's a
really good relationship between James
Carville and Mary Matalin who's a very
well-known Republican strategist and she
was a great touchstone to and they are
sparring together from opposite sides
but they have this relationship you know
and it's very kind of sexy and they are
there's a chemistry and electricity
between them and I think that was one of
the inspirations but for for faith and
for Gary
as far as American politics and
Australian politics do you feel like
you've learned anything about American
politics while making this that's
completely different from Australian all
all of the money that's involved you
know it's just extraordinary you know
I've been to the conventions before and
it's like going to the the Emmy Awards
you know where is this politics is far
less kind of dramatic and it's very much
more low-key and you know Australians
are more pride themselves on taking
themselves as seriously in America it's
just larger than life and that's the
politics as well Carl Jack Hastings is
our key back into the great now swing
state of Wisconsin he just doesn't know
it yet my first question to you was as a
Canadian was there anything interesting
about American politics that you learned
from doing this film Chris Chris you you
kind of got your start through a
political cinema kind of like in the
earlier days and I kind of was curious
how much political cinema has changed
over like these thirty years oh boy I
think it has changed in a big big way
and I believe you're talking about when
we used to have an independent film
industry you know and John Sayles the
granddaddy of independent film gave me
my first job and we have worked closely
together for five films and a lot of
them have a couple of them have been
very political pieces but it's become
tougher and tougher harder and harder to
get the finances that's the bit that's
the big oh wow nobody nobody wants to
like help make some of these pieces it's
very hard to find the money now yeah
yeah all right Oh interesting I didn't
see it going there
you both you both play pretty honorable
characters I was wondering if there's
anything you envy particularly about
your characters
I just hope maybe I brought my own
honesty to the character and I must say
I'm a go I pay attention to the news way
too much
people like John Stewart and and others
can talk circles around me politically
you know I know my gut reactions but to
talk really intelligently not too easy
Mackenzie's like incredibly dense
intractable parts of politics that can't
possibly be changed and I think she has
a realistic clarity and and went to
dismantling what he uses okay now what
about like as far as your previous
characters that you've played I'm
curious as to which you would think
would make a good politician or do you
think that would be good to like run for
any particular office oh man no I'd say
I'd say talk to my first film that John
gave me playing joke Hannah Hannah Union
man our politics were armed and remain
very very much the same so yeah Jim
might my character Johanna Han would be
a good man running for politics fire but
I'd like to see her try I am telling you
guys that could be the real deal this
little camp
and of ours has caught the attention of
the National Republican Party why are
you here because crushing the last piece
of hope in your eyes really gets me off
it's good to see you
yeah you look fat